this definition what's interesting is
that a look a motive how will the
relation between between relationship
between chemistry and other fields
change the future well that's the same
thing I just answered actually it's
already changed in a way that not many
people appreciate and certainly people
who are non scientists and across the
number of scientists who are running
universities today is is very poor i
mean if chemistry had as bad a
reputation as economics house of the
present time or politics of many other
subjects and they wouldn't be vice
chancellors and charge of you mean but
you know chemistry has a pretty good
reputation from penicillin the harbor
process and various polymers and stuff
like that so chemistry is a subject
which has made massively positive
contributions to society few negative
ones obviously but that's the way
science inside society uses it and
whereas somehow economics economists and
politicians seem to be able to get away
with murder when they're the sort of
area is a bunch of cobblers as far as
i'm concerned and but it has changed
already and as i said people don't
really understand that and if they go
down the line and say that chemistry is
a dog that's had its day they will be
making a massive mistake because in many
ways it's almost a sort of language of
understanding of the world in which we
live and i don't see how you can do
really great molecular biology without a
really deep understanding of chemistry
and i think of course i would say that
wouldn't I but I i feel that very
strongly the change has already occurred
we need to ensure that the future there
are departments are people in them who
can talk together the coffee room
our chemistry about condensed matter
physics I mean in my case radio
astronomy was very important and it was
our early work in 1975 Dave Walton
myself making carbon chains with a
student Alexander and then working with
Takeshi ochre and Canadian astronomers
lon Avery Norbert man John McLeod where
we just to cover the carbon change in
space an interest in radio astronomy led
to my ideas about Carmen and space and
the chance meeting with Rick's Molly who
created the apparatus whose rehearse on
death row was to discover c16 that was
because Bob Carol said you know Rick's
doing some interesting stuff gon go over
and have a look and I think that lesson
is an important one yeah the others
research which is focused we want to
make a better transistor we wanted to
get our lasers that are sort of
lithographic process to be finer the
sunny other there's only so far you can
go the next breakthrough will have to be
if there is one will be in molecular
computing and we've got a molecular
thing in our head which is pretty
amazing so it can be done it was done by
biology a long time ago and it's all
chemistry I mean we are sort of complex
test tubes in which chemistry a lot of
chemistry occurs